estoy muy entusiasmado de que the heart
nos acompañó hoy en la oficina y hoy en
la mañana teníamos una plática sumamente
matemática de un tema fascinante y le
mencionaba
acerca de algo genial llamado la ley de
benford la ley de benford y que es la
ley de benford este fenómeno extraño que
obtenemos cuando estamos viendo los
números en la vida real entonces por
ejemplo tenemos estas gráficas aquí si
tomamos la población de todos los países
y decimos bueno qué tal si el primer
dígito ya sea un millón diez mil 100 mil
inicia con uno entonces contamos a todos
los países cuyo primer dígito inician
con uno supongo en este caso tenemos 27
hay 27 si todos los que su población
empiece con 1 ya sea un día es un 17 un
millón un billón no hablar mucho más
todos éstos estarán en esta clase
y si índice con dos cae en la segunda
clase y así se sigue mejor otro color
pero continúa exacto está mejor queda
genial y mejor contraste la pregunta es
tú crees que aquí tienes números al azar
si para el primer dígito es una especie
de número al azar ajax y digo hay
enormes diferencias en las poblaciones
de países algunos tienen millones
algunos no sé cuál sea el mayor o
cualquier lugar
hammond tener o no es un país tan ser
chispas cuál es ese que está en la
riviera francesa la cara podríamos tomar
s
no lo sé yo estaría interesado en verlo
para poblaciones estados y todo el
vaticano es el país más pequeño eso es
lo que yo creo si no es eso aún cuenta
creo que depende como cuentes el
vaticano cuenta no sé exactamente puedes
estar en 502.000 es entonces entonces
por qué estás pidiendo esto porque
estamos viendo más unos que dos
qué está pasando a un efecto es una
pequeña probabilidad
como platicábamos es más probable tener
domicilios con número impar que par de
eso estábamos hablando previamente si
recientemente aprendiendo y tiene
sentido médica vamos a cualquier casa
podría tener un número uno para cada
calle si tu casa inicia con casa 1 casa
2 casas 3 si tiene un número impar de
casas entonces tu calle tiene más
números impares exacto y si tienes un
número par tienes la misma correcto y
eso se inician con uno que es impar y
las poblaciones necesarias de los
números que íbamos hablando o sea
tenemos una pequeña ligera probabilidad
tal vez un 50 punto algo de tener una
casa con un número impar o que tenga un
1 a diferencia de cualquier otra cosa y
más o menos que se esperaría
efectivamente esto es lo que
esperaríamos pero aquí es una
probabilidad mucho mayor de que tomemos
poblaciones de países al azar y empiecen
con un 1 a diferencia que fuera con 18 o
exacto y no solo ves esto en países sino
también lo ves mucho en finanzas como
cuánto dinero gana una empresa cuánto
pierde y el humo aparece más
frecuentemente como el primero en
frecuencia lfi y aquí tenemos otra
gráfica elegante aunque está
completamente alocada es el primer
dígito de constante es eficaz entonces
que serán ejemplos de constantes físicas
y estoy suponiendo que no sabemos
exactamente cuáles son las que están
aquí pero lo más probable es que es la
constante gravitacional la constante de
planck y lo que es realmente loco de
todo esto es que las constantes físicas
normalmente están asociadas a las
unidades con las que las mides y muchas
otras cosas
y no sabemos exactamente cuáles son las
constantes físicas que están aquí pero
lo más probable es que empiezan con el
dígito 1 y que tarde o temprano cumplen
la ley de benford y de hecho aquí el
reto es bueno primero ven forester chico
de los lentes y si claro seguro que lo
estás preguntando no son ambos
transporte el no es el caso de que sea
benford antes de rasurarse y después de
rasurarse puede que pueda este que está
aquí es benford y gracias a él la ley
lleva su nombre bueno también pusimos a
este señor de aquí que no sea rasurado
con barba este menú consta en un año y
con concisión ese apellido newcombe y
fue el primero en denunciar la ley de
benford claro sin utilizar el nombre de
benford y tenía la mejor barba bueno
está aquí porque es todo un personaje
bueno al menos para mí y este de acá
esto análisis como un personaje del cine
o una estrella entonces la pregunta es
cuál es el caso puro de esto digo cuando
tenemos esta información vemos algunas
fluctuaciones variaciones como en
nuestro país y bueno aquí nuestro
ejemplo el tamaño es bastante bajo en la
prueba o sea no sigue totalmente la
perfección además se va a enfocar todos
esos que habían en la unión soviética y
también no sabemos cuántas constantes
físicas fueron las que muestrearon aquí
pero es increíblemente cercano a la ley
de benford exacto y bueno cuando vemos
esta otra gráfica esta es como la
representación de la lectura de benford
la ley pura de benford si esta curva que
está aquí que fue aproximada con
muchísimos datos pero lo que es
realmente impresionante de esto es que
si tomamos construcción es puramente
matemáticas como por ejemplo las
potencias de dos o como la gente con
aquí y si entonces tomamos sólo el
primer dígito si el primer dígito y lo
ponemos en estas barras vamos a ver cómo
están es sacar no matemáticamente
matemáticamente si tomamos las potencias
de 2 entonces tenemos 2 4 8 16 32 64 y
sigamos creciendo esto entonces tenemos
128 256 512 y seguimos y continuamos y
continuamos y luego nos preguntamos
cuántos de estos números empiezan con 1
y lo revisamos y vamos seleccionando los
que empiezan con uno bueno los que su
dígito más significativo es un 1 y este
también y luego los contamos y tomamos
el porcentaje de todos los que hay y
luego nos vamos con los que empiezan con
2 y éste empieza con 2 y así continuamos
con los otros números tal vez tendríamos
que utilizar un programa de computadora
porque pues vamos a utilizar números muy
grandes y luego pues nos preguntaríamos
cuál es el porcentaje de los que
empiezan con 2 y observaríamos que
perfectamente perfectamente cumple la
ley de benford esto es algo más al tanto
mágico y bonacci también y nada más es
para las potencias de 2 es para
cualquiera
las potencias de 10 o números números
mezclados potencias de géneros potencias
de 10 este no esas no van a funcionar
pero -ha indicado- tiene razón
números que ese mes de hecho hay cierta
cantidad conexión nos cobraran la
distribución de benford y lo que
nosotros queremos es d
ártica desafiarte a pensar por qué
ocurre esto y que nos escribas tus ideas
en nuestra página y en los foros que
tenemos el desafío es para explicar por
qué ocurre esto nosotros también vamos a
dar una explicación perfecta laro
nuestra versión eso lo vamos a hacer en
otro vídeo si mejor hagámoslo en otro
vídeo claro